There's been a big turnout for early voting
in the US, with long lines at many polling
stations like this one in Los Angeles County.
But one group was noticeably absent, as many
election volunteers noticed.
I haven’t seen a lot of Latinos today.
That's come as a surprise --since one Latin-American
issue has played a big role in the campaign:
the migrants making their way to the US-Mexican
border from Central America.
President Trump has put the issue of illegal
migration at the forefront of his campaigning
for the Republicans -- blaming the Democrats
for allowing them into the United States.
Democrats hope to turn Latino discontent over
Trump’s migration rhetoric into votes.
But they don't have a detailed strategy for
the diverse Latino community, according to
Sonja Diaz, the head of a Latino think tank.
Almost 60% of Latinos surveyed in a national
poll had not received any sort of information
or communication from a candidate.
Latino interest groups are trying to fill
the void.
Many, such as the immigrants’ rights organization
CHIRLA in Los Angeles, have set up call centers.
Volunteers have translated voter guides and
are reaching out to potential voters.
Six out of 10 Latinos are millennials, and
many are voting for the first time.
The latest polls have shown that less than
half of them know who’s running in their
respective districts.
With the political rhetoric high, and a growing
distrust in the government and its institutions,
many have simply tuned out.
"The Trump administration has had a very negative
affect on the way Latinos view the elections
because we now believe that our vote does
not count or it's not going to affect the
administration."
Kevin de León is a Democratic candidate for
Senator.
He's been one of the most visible of all the
Latino candidates in California.
And he's been urging Democrats to articulate
a position beyond “Stop Trump”.
During a campaign rally at his favorite Taco
vendor, De Leon called on Latinos to vote
for his fellow Democrats to help win back
the House of Representatives.
It’s critical that in these very dangerous
times in our nation’s history that we engage
in the battle for the soul of our nation against
a president without one, that the Latino vote
comes out strong, that come Tuesday November
6 we send a very clear message that we are
one America.
Latino voters represent one of the fastest
growing demographics in the United States.
This year's midterms may indicate whether
the Democrats have found the key to mobilising
them at the polls.